[Musique]
a maintenant français a bien sûr je
prends plaisir plus longtemps suis en
france et voilà vous avez une langue
très très très joli
[Musique]
ah je préfère chanter quand même oui
mais largement repensé c'est très
fatigant moi j'ai beaucoup me suis
beaucoup amusé m j'ai beaucoup souffert
aussi à ça ça personne nous démonter des
choisir au frais ça parce que c'est
parce que le même métier donc c'est très
difficile à gérer
là j'ai mon coeur partagé en deux on a
testé la chine a préféré on pourra dire
un de ces licences il autres cellules a
bossé voilà et les rouleurs comme mon
nom des grands coups durs le single
sensing quelques c'est une balade on
pourra dire nostalgie festive et c'est
une chanson qui parle de l'amour ça
parle que la bourse était cuillère et
que l'amour ça se passe en hiver plutôt
comprends pas ce que l'on veut c'est là
où se serrent dans les bras 12 voilà
c'est l'histoire de l'amour passé
et voilà qu'on connaît tous jurent donc
et l'album si un album de chansons avec
avec un univers complètement hispanique
avec des guitares castagnettes avec
voilà plein de soleil
leurs chansons festives quelques
ballades amour aussi et voilà c'est un
album avec lesquels j'ai c'est de
ramener le soleil la chaleur mais
l'espagne
j'essaye de les chanter l'amour à la vie
voilà c'est un avion pour faire l'amour
et faire la fête